[Music]  [Music]  I discovered a third species of sea  dragons and new species that we had no  idea existed in the ocean two days no  one has seen a ruby sea dragon alive all  the specimens we know are sitting in  museums or have been washed up on  beaches now what we need our life  observations of its behavior Norfolk  habitat we're going to the remote areas  of Western Australia where we found the  blue sea dragon for the first time and  since it seems to be living at greater  depth then we can safely scuba dive too  we will use a little remotely operated  vehicle that has cameras and bright  lights attached to it and we will lower  into the water and it will communicate  with us on a boat and will fear it  through the water and we will look for  the red needle in the haystack I fully  expected that we knew all the sea dragon  species that are out there but the  discovery showed us that we can still  find a charismatic bright red fish that  no one has ever seen before  [Music]